good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is empower people
over the youth sundar pichai the thing
which attracted me to Google and to
Internet in general is that it's a great
equalizer right
and so to me always being struck by the
fact that Google search work the same
mm-hmm it's as long as you had access to
computer with connectivity if you were a
rule kid anywhere or if you were a
professor at Stanford or hard work and
and to me you know I want Google to
strive to push to do that not just build
technology for a certain segments right
for me it's it matters that you know we
drive technology as a as an equalizing
force as an enabler to everyone around
the world I think the best thing that
you can do is create a product or
service that empowers people that's what
we do as entrepreneurs we see a problem
we see an opportunity we want to make a
difference in the world
we want to make money yes but we want to
have an impact we want to empower people
we want the output that we are creating
to touch people's lives in some way and
I think that's the most gratifying thing
that you can do as an entrepreneur to
know that the thing that you spent all
this time and energy and effort and put
it into the world is being received
great and people like it but it's
empowering them to do more in their
lives and in their businesses it's why
my youtube channel is so fun for me is
so amazing for me to wake up and see
your comments every day because I know
the work that I do is empowering that
allows you to go off and do hopefully
amazing things you know I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve every problem
in the world the major problem it's not
big corporations it's entrepreneurs and
so I can help by giving you content by
giving you inspiration by giving you
strategies and tactics to help your
businesses
become better if I play a quarter
percent role in helping you get better
and build your company I know that's
going to have a ripple effect out and
that's why my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs because if I can touch a
billion entrepreneurs in a quarter of a
percent way that is massive world change
that's what gets me pumped up that's why
I love doing what I do I want to empower
you guys to do great things if I look at
this business trying to dance salsa
people come to learn how to dance salsa
but really they're coming for other
reasons right the they're lonely they
want to meet people they're looking for
relationships looking for some friends
they're looking to build their
self-confidence is always a deeper
reason for why they come here and people
always leave feeling happier with
themselves feeling more confident maybe
meeting some new friends and that
empowers them in their entire life not
just in the one hour where they come in
and learn how to do a turn right we're
empowering them to live a better life
for the rest of the life because of the
time that they spent in our class that's
exciting that's energizing it's what we
stand for and so if you are focused on
creating a product or service that yes
can make money but has an impact by
empowering people to do great things in
their lives and their businesses I think
that's the ultimate most satisfying
thing that you can create as an
entrepreneur so the question I have for
you guys today is what are you doing to
empower others let me know let me feel
the passion you got for it leave it down
in the comments below super curious to
find out I also want to give a quick
shout out to in Randy Niemann thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word really really really means
a lot to me and I hope you're enjoying
the read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
for this recipe we go
you know the traditional reform mindset
towards education is let's micromanage
teachers more like a good number of
really great teachers are getting
handicapped by this micromanaging
teaching to the test or whatever else
and forcing like on Tuesday September
27th you have to cover this and you
can't question that and you have to say
it in these words and you have no time
to run your own project and you have no
time to think of your own curriculum or
whatever you want to do we genuinely
feel like the teachers are getting
liberated here do what you want on every
day and the students are going to what
what they wanted to say and we're
freeing tons of class time for you to do
what I think you went into teaching to
begin with like when I when I ran my
little summer camp and you know I will
claim them thirty years of experience in
all the rest of what was fun for me was
not having to give a lecture on least
common multiple Ektron probability to
know that that was out of the way and
getting to do the super-fun simulation
where the kids are trading pieces and
others and I got the felt like I was
able to express my creativity I was able
to go home and see what would be a
really cool way to understand to
understand this concept intuitively and
when I went to classroom that's what we
did and I felt like it was a much richer
experience and so I we genuinely feel
and we generally hope that it's doing
that for teachers and the teachers of
Los Altos have expressed that that they
love that if you liberated they feel
like they have data that they've never
had before it's like the fifth grade
teachers they don't they teach all the
classes because they're in elementary
school and they feel handicapped in
their other classes because they are
doing that the lecture they are doing
the stuff that I would say is lower
value than what they're doing in their
math classes which is the projects which
are the one-on-one interactions and so
they're they're actually asking us as
quickly as possible when are the when
are the grammar videos coming one of the
grammar exercises coming so I can do
more interesting things with that part
of my day in in class I've heard the
story that the first line of code that
you wrote was an apartment in Campbell
that's right not too far from the
chemistry that's right I mean did you
have any idea you know you wrote this
you put it out on the Internet yeah you
didn't sort of do it thinking hey I'm
going to build an 83 billion dollar
business course not at all not at all
really I mean it was just this as I said
I as a software engineer I wanted to
write some tools that I thought could be
useful to
ordinary ordinary people regular people
I had a day job started as a nights and
weekends
project and it's amazing of course now
you know we all understand code does
change the world and you know it can
change people's lives but I think what
makes eBay unique despite the fact there
are many sort of now there are more
marketplace businesses out there we
really have always been about people
it's only been about bringing tools to
ordinary people and giving them the
tools and the opportunities that they
need that they can use to then be
successful and define success in their
own way so yeah those early those early
weeks and months were crazy you know so
I remember one of the very first items
listed this was in 1995 in September of
1995 one of the very first items listed
was a 1952 silver dawn rolls-royce okay
and and the seller and I wish we could
find a seller the seller was amazing
because he or she had done this
beautiful listing and so you know you
could put HTML in there and the seller
had created a server somewhere to
actually host photos back in those days
you know you had to actually only you
know run your own server to host photos
and actually had these beautiful listing
on there I looked at that and I said
this is incredible there is no way
anyone will ever buy a car on the
internet like that's just ridiculous
that'll never happen Edwards now there's
a car sold every four minutes on a
mobile device I mean it's incredible
still incredible so who could have could
have imagined it how do you motivate
people to get things done
you know I'm the reason why I paused was
I was trying not to come up with a with
a try to answer I I think and this is a
much used to an overused term I think
defining a overall goal that that's
reaching in that it isn't easily
attainable and then empowering and this
is the overused word and then empowering
people to actually go try and get it and
ensuring that when they when they have a
misstep that you're there to to help
them long is it's probably the way to I
mean you know to be frank with you most
of the people that we hired the Lord who
are extremely smart they're
self-motivated they're very hardworking
and you've got too much like a racehorse
you've got to make sure that you give
them the space to to develop and mature
and and accomplish so I think most of my
partner's would would say the same thing
I mean it takes it takes an element of
defining the ultimate destination then
empowering people to actually go to
achievement